[Music]
well david you're on the air
hi doc wallick i had a couple of
questions for you
um i'm 56 i mean i think i'm in
relatively good shape i weigh 155
160 and five by four
some of that's muscle weight i would
assume um
i'm having a hard time with diabetes and
i can't seem to
get rid of it i've been trying all kinds
of different stuff
she wants to put me and my doctor wants
to put me on insulin and i'm trying to
avoid that okay want to know what else
you got
is the second question with you also
second question yeah you said you had a
couple of issues
well that and you know well actually i
just want to know
uh like taking um that
super beats is that good for me do you
have something that i can take
okay okay uh let's stop
okay okay we have to appreciate you have
type 2 diabetes type job is a very
simple nutritional deficiency disease
it's not genetic in any way shape or
form do you have any skin issues
no okay you have any gray hair
i have a little bit in my beard but i
don't really have a lot on my head
okay what about your legs you got any
varicose veins or spider veins
not that i noticed i haven't really
looked but i don't think so okay we'll
have a look okay
anyway okay do you have any bowel
problems constipation diarrhea irritable
bowel syndrome
colitis diverticulitis okay none of that
okay good all right what's going on here
um well he needs to
clean his diet up no wheat barley rye or
oats no fried foods no burnt animal fat
and no oils of any kind
and then he's uh because of his weight
he's gonna need
two packs i'd get him on one healthy
blood sugar pack and one healthy
brain and heart pack that way it covers
everything
and he can add an extra bottle of
sweeties and or glycogenics to that
and he should get rid of it should work
i mean
as long as he cleans up his diet it'll
work
yeah and so let's see here
so you know if you're on any medication
david what you want to do is stay on the
medication and to begin with keep taking
your blood sugar as you should
and as your blood sugar drops you can
slowly reduce your medication based on
you know the actual numbers but type 2w
is one of the easiest things to get rid
of it's a simple nutritional deficiency
but ashar said and you know she said at
first you got to get rid of all the bad
stuff so you can absorb the nutrients no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat broth notes no sugar
you need to eat like an asian and of
course arizona
when you look at their numbers um you
know they
are the ones in the states is spiking
all the time and
it's one of those crazy crazy things
where
they have uh let's see here
um arizona it just drives you crazy
when you look at the various
amounts of
infections okay and things that go on
because everybody eats gluten
arizona is 40 50 60 latino
black and indigenous peoples because
you know well the location
of southwest and as a result
it's crazy the pima indians there forty
percent of the women
have diabetes type two diabetes and
sixty percent of the men have type two
you're not a pima indian are you david
no sir hispanic though
and that was my thing a few years back
when i was younger i actually went in
for
a a physical because my mother insisted
i went in for a physical
and so i when i went in i felt like i
was pretty good shape and when i came
out i
felt pretty bad i had high cholesterol
so i took
the metformin or something like that i
think that's what it was
and then when i came back for my well
women
with metformin would be for diabetes oh
that meant brain
i can't remember it was some kind of
cholesterol medicine i can't remember
the name yeah
it was a statement yeah so when i went
in for my retest again
he goes okay we're not going to worry
about the cholesterol anymore
but now you got diabetes my my
cholesterol stayed the same
but my diabetes dropped about but
diabetes came up all of a sudden
so then when i started going back to the
gym i dropped the i dropped the
the cholesterol but then the diabetes
showed back up again or it stayed
so yeah okay so anyway as shark says you
know get off all the bad foods
you have to one healthy brain heart pack
uh take a half of those everything twice
a day get one
healthy blood sugar pack but get an
extra bottle of sweetie so you can take
three twice a day at least
and then you know check your blood sugar
as often as you should
and um if you're are you on medication
for the diabetes
yes sir like i said they want to keep me
on no
no they want to push on did but are you
on metformin or anything like that now
are you on our old medications yes i'm
on
i'm on uh oh gotta get through i don't
have a bottle okay that's right that's
right
but the fact that it doesn't work very
well is because you are eating gluten
and your intestines are dead
you cannot absorb the medication that's
the problem that's why they want to go
to the injectable
okay and they're going to milk you like
a cow okay
so what you need to do is follow char's
advice uh and call us every two weeks
and let us know what your blood sugar is
did you have an a1c
taken yeah it was high
okay
or something i think yeah it should be
four yeah okay so yeah watch it that a1c
will come right down we have people have
been like
15 to 19 for 25 years and in a month's
time it's down to four
okay so follow char's advice and call us
every two weeks and
you're gonna have a great testimony
you'll help a lot of people as you age
factors like health weight diet and
lifestyle
can all impact your bones joints and
general mobility
even everyday exercise can lead to wear
and tear on your body
over time you might start to experience
stiffness or pain due to damaged joints
or connective tissue
ultimate glucogel by youngevity was
created to help you limit the effects of
wear on your joints
it delivers a daily dose of collagen
rich gelatin your body needs for joint
elasticity
and maintenance ultima gluco gel
contains a one to one ratio of gelatin
and glucosamine sulfate
which is a key building block of your
bone matrix cartilage
ligaments tendons and connective tissue
gelatin's unique blend of amino acids
not only help with muscle and joint
health but also has been shown to
provide additional benefits for the
brain
skin and hair ultimate glucogel
natural optimal daily support for joint
health
to learn more contact your youngevity
associate
a strong heart is a happy heart your
body systems depend on a healthy
cardiovascular system to thrive
without a healthy heart you could
experience symptoms like fatigue
aches and pains dizziness or shortness
of breath
proper nutrition is crucial to your
cardiovascular health
youngevity developed ultimate efa plus
with a proprietary balanced blend of
essential fatty acids
from borage flax and fish oils to help
make sure you get the nutrients your
heart needs
we started with flaxseed oil it's been
shown to improve the elasticity of
arteries and support healthy blood
pressure
next we included cold water fish oils
rich in omega-3s that can promote a
healthy cardiovascular system
and even increase levels of good hdl
cholesterol
then we added borage oil known for its
powerful
anti-inflammatory properties blended
together
these essential fatty acids provide you
with the optimal blend of nutrients to
help maintain normal cardiovascular
health
ultimate efa plus the right nutrients to
improve your heart health
naturally to learn more contact your
youngevity associate
you